Nationals now back on British soil now
we understand that the plane won't be
hanging around long the 83 British
nationals and some military and medical
personnel will disembark and then the
plane will leave to go to Spain where
those 19 Spanish Nationals and other EU
Nationals will get off the plane there
what will happen here is the plane we
understand is going to taxi at the end
of this runway left and just to the left
of ours off our screen at the moment is
a number of aeromedical ambulances from
RAF Brize Norton RAF Brize Norton of
course the tactical medical wing base
for the whole of the RAF this is the RAF
base when it comes to logistics and very
well equipped in terms of the expertise
and the facilities here to deal with a
situation like this it's been a long
flight more than 11 hours from Wuhan we
don't know exactly how long those
British nationals on board are going to
stay at pryzen awesome before they get
on those coaches seven coaches which we
saw leaving reading this morning they
arrived here around ten o'clock this
morning morning Brian Norton coaches
which have been hired which will take
those British nationals up to the world
that's where they're going to be kept in
quarantine away from their family for
the next 14 days important to stress of
course that we don't know whether anyone
is ill on that plane but we do
understand that if anyone onboard that
plane whether it was the British
nationals whether it is the Spanish
Nationals or anyone else fairly showed
symptoms linked to karana virus during
the flight and that may well have
happened we don't know but if that has
happened then there is an isolation part
separate from the rest of the passengers
on board that plane and we understand
that if anybody is showing specific
symptoms then they are going to be taken
to one of the NHS facilities those four
hospitals which are equipped to deal
with a situation like this